on a microscopic level the Earth's spin
rate and axis are changing constantly
the drift of continents changes in ocean
currents and the rebounding of the crust
since the retreat of Ice Age glaciers
all shift mass around an alter Earth's
spin rate and axis even hurricanes and
earthquakes can give the earth a tiny
nudge this way or that we need this
exact information to launch rockets
without these Corrections GPS satellites
would drift into irrelevance within
weeks right now we rely on very long
baseline interferometry to track Earth's
rotation and spin axis but the system
requires dozens of observatories to give
a valuable astronomy time and computing
the results can sometimes take days by
contrast the roaming ring laser promises
to make fast and potentially continuous
measurements
this is Romi being built over the course
of six months at the end it's buried
underground with only a few access
points sticking up last month it turned
on all four of its triangular laser
rings for the first time Romi like other
ring lasers relies on the Sania effect
in which two beams travel in opposite
directions around the same path because
the earth is rotating in the direction
of one of the lasers it incurs an extra
path link that the laser accommodates by
stretching its wavelengths and lowering
its frequency the frequency of the
counter rotating laser Rises when
interfered the slightly clashing lasers
frequencies create beats the same
pulsing beats that piano tuners try to
eliminate as they strike a note and a
tuning fork at the same time the beat
frequency is a direct measure of the
rotation that causes it with this 12
meter arms Romi is more sensitive than
smaller ring lasers and instead of one
square ring it has four triangular ones
three are required to put down rotations
in any direction while the fourth adds
redundancy being so new however Romi is
plagued by experimental drift the
machine is settling in soft sediments
and it's still tubes will flex with the
temperature swings of day and night
scientists will try to isolate and
eliminate these sources of noise but
there is one type of noise that
scientists
want Roma to capture tilt motions from
earthquakes traditionally seismologists
could only measure translation or
displacements along any of the three
cardinal axes but earthquakes also
contain tilt motions which rotate the
ground without shifting it engineers
have been designing buildings for only
one type of shaking when really they
should be designed for the two different
inputs
although Romi can record these motions
from distant earthquakes it can't move
that's why scientists want to build
smaller portable rotation sensors based
on fiber optics that can be sent out to
measure tilt motions around the world
[Music]
[Music]